more unpopular nutrition truths that
Wellness influencers don't want you to
know
The Dirty Dozen is an unscientific
marketing tactic to get you to buy more
expensive produce
this juice isn't the sole cause of
disease and this juice isn't the cure
for it
CMOS is definitely super nutritious but
there are way less expensive less fishy
and less gloopy ways to get your
nutritional fix
Eating Disorders aren't just skinny
white girl problems so don't judge a
book by its cover
kid cereal isn't going to cause cancer
your kid would have to consume a
thousand cups of Cheerios a day to meet
the very conservative acceptable limit
most anti-bloat supplements that
influence those petal are literally just
laxatives that help you poop
[Applause]
we actually wouldn't want to reset our
gut if we did influencers would be
begging their doctors for antibiotics
GMOs aren't killing you they're actually
saving lives all around the world which
of these nutrition truths are going to
make the most influencers mad